this game but we do have Alejandro in
Zagreb with one Gary Kasparov Alejandro
take it away
thank you Christian we're here with the
13th World chess champion Gary Casper
welcome to the show enjoying the
grantchester so far absolutely
absolutely and I enjoyed it more than
last year because I'm watching
it's definitely a different feeling yeah
absolutely
tell us a little bit about your events
here in Croatia we don't we have not
only the grand chess tour but it's a
whole festival of Chess around us yeah
absolutely it's it's that was the whole
idea to actually to use branches to
prevent
as a booster for chess in Croatia and
the whole region so I had one of my
Chris projects Foundation branches here
KCF Adriatic and uh you know it's uh
this tournament is ideal opportunity to
bring Croatian kids kids from
neighboring countries they play uh but
on top of that we also have the special
session with European stars and this
year of course where all the ukrainians
so that was also quite an experience
two of them were really good especially
this is the I was very impressed by a 10
year old kid yeah it's uh somehow you
know the the universe works in a very
strange fashion he's from butcher so we
all know the the name of the city for
tragedy and for atrocities and crimes
committed by Russian troops but we may
may know the city as a place of one of
the greatest talents again could be too
early to say but in at age 10 to show
such a maturity such a mature
understanding of the game and so I I was
impressed and also Igor salmonenke of
his I am at age 13 and so yeah Ukraine
definitely has talent so that's that's
it's not just you know the war where but
it's it's the the country is still very
generous with with talents I'm sure not
only in chess but I think that you know
we will we will hear more about uh
Ukrainian Ukrainian teams winning events
in the future 10-13 and it's just like
they get getting younger and younger
these talents are amazing yeah look now
they have access to to data to
information that you know I remember
myself you know that age you know trying
just to collect you know just the pieces
of information from newspapers from
chess magazines you know making you know
the clips and uh and and writing
something from the books and now they
just have to push a button or just you
know swipe their finger on the screen
and
um so they they learn fast
um and of course they can play a lot of
tournaments so we didn't have the same
luxury yet so at the age 12 13 they
already experienced International
Players so this is now uh we Grandmaster
at age 12 uh yeah yeah it's no one is
surprised so about it anymore so it's
the
um and um again I I'm very pleased that
you know in Croatia so what is this my
adopted country so the chess is now is
gaining popularity and there's a big
support from the government
and and of course you know super bad
super United in croatians their their
company
it's it's already you know making
commitments for for at least for the
next year so it seems that you know with
a superbet sponsorship chess uh gained
new grounds in Eastern Europe Bucharest
Warsaw Zagreb so I think it's it's great
because we we have many talents in this
part of the world but not many
tournaments so actually when I was
active chess player I accepted yugoslava
I never played in Eastern Europe because
it was something blog and they were
secondary tournaments right yeah um and
now uh you know we see you know quite a
quite a boost and I'm I've no doubt that
you know all these events you know in
that like one in Zagreb or Bucharest
they will help to
um not not just generate interest but
also will bring new talents young
talents from the respective countries
it's been an explosion of talent from
here from neighboring countries and we
see it everywhere everybody trying to be
the next Magnus talk about a little bit
about the tournament especially because
Magnus now is only worth retirement
is representative of the Chess World
everybody's fighting for second place
and Magnus Head and Shoulders still
ahead of everybody look it's interesting
because it's you know um we I I mean I
know I I yeah I was you know it's I
wasn't issues so that's this because
everybody wants you to lose everybody
wanted you know just YouTube to falter
and and I think it's some artists I
think in the in the beginning of the
tournament Magnus was yeah he was it was
you could feel you could feel that he
was uneasy yeah I think it's a big
statement that he has been preparing and
uh and uh he was probably not sure
what's next and and it showed and as his
game was not very convincing so not at
all and then it is it's at one point
everyone said oh maybe he's now going
down boom there's a trade Magnus was
back on the rails back on track
yesterday was an incredible amount of
Victory seven wins two losses no draws
at all and today
aggressive Styles and it's also you know
it's energy so it's the yo you why watch
his games as if his pieces have more
energy so it's the I think he's not
taking on you know a secondary position
so there's all all the best players in
the world are here so but they were no
match and they will see what happens now
so it's the uh it's a relatively slow
start for him
relatively slow start he's still way
ahead one and a half points that's how
he started the day yeah but it's it's
it's it's it's also it's the it's the
he's very um he's very uh stable so this
is It's he's you know look at his
performance so this is even if he's not
doing great so he's still on top well uh
the the players you know it's uh some of
them had a great day yesterday but you
know but they're not doing well today
mvl yesterday was not you know look very
Bleak today he just you know he's doing
great but you know it's uh again as you
said you know this this the second third
you know positions could change Magnum
steel you know stands on top the world
champion is not going to be defending
his title and the is the same in the
women's section who you find is not
participating in the world championship
cycle at all are the matches just not as
important for these top of the top
players or what's going on look
um
we can have a long philosophical
discussion what is the world title
it's the legally yeah you can say
legally today you can make a case that
Phoebe owns the world championship match
though you can still you know have tons
of arguments about it because
um and that's what the argument I had
was feeding in the 90s right uh when I
walked away though I just you know
defended magic games The Challenge and I
just saw just out to defeated because uh
Phoebe never called but winning the
first world champion but when it was the
six right so which means he inherited
tradition that existed before feeding so
from 1886 to 1948 so there were five
world champions and and feed it
basically included them Incorporated
them so we know about 16 world champions
so we we cherish our history going back
to Steines right some could say even
probably you know you can go
beyond so this is or just back in the
timeline and talking about morphy but
let's start with official quote-unquote
official Championship so 1886 by the way
Saint Louis
well I played the role in this event
that how they started yes
um and um and this you know this kind of
collisions has never been resolved
technically you can say that in in 2002
when we signed this agreement in Prague
because it was myself and kramnik so
yeah we somehow uh abandoned our rights
you know this as world champion so we
merged you know feed the line with the
with the uh historical line
um and and then when kramnik play top of
so that says everything has been you
know um
um Amalgamated but still you know the
question is Magnus is the best player
today and and for the public he's the
cold world champion whatever title you
want to do to add to his name he's still
the best and I it will be very hard to
see any match hold world championship
match without magnets I don't know this
answer was collusion but because at the
end of the day I don't know that's
fantasize what if what if Magnus plays
yarn outs I mean just you know or
whoever so how are you going to handle
it so this is who will consider match
let's again say uh Nepal playing ding
well I don't know where we're going to
play so this is the so play what it will
be considered the match or a match or
you know it will just uh you know bring
us back to the situation on late 90s and
it's just yeah with all due respect to
let's say to California and and and and
qasim Jana yeah I'm sorry that's that's
not not exactly though the the world
champions that that are remembered
because he also had by the way also feed
a hat uh its own world championships
back in 19 I think it was almost back in
1924 I think the Madison was the first
one of Philly Congress anyway they even
had the Boogaloo buff and that's that's
that's that's that's that's how they
actually use bogalubo as a challenge
tour to a local so maybe someone someone
else I mean this is Phoebe had its own
you know Champions yes with the amateurs
Champions and and uh and the uh like the
big league always opposed back back back
then in before World War II uh any of
the attempts to intervene so it's back
in 1937 1938 so it was all you know like
a club so yeah again I don't have
answers for that
um so I think that's going back to what
you said uh it's maybe this is the old
format just he's easy roll-on maybe we
should look for something like
granchester Magnum made the statement I
I didn't pay much attention to what he
said at the opening ceremony that he
strongly preferred branches to format
with classic rabbit and bullets 2D
traditional uh um cycle maybe that's an
answer again we don't want play you know
just for for fun we play for public and
if there is a public demand to to to
make these changes maybe we should
consider it and we asked a lot of the
players under interviews why would you
due to change the world championship
form and a ton of them said the current
format is our cake they would prefer
shortage time controls well I think that
we should look something like Grant's
tour it's this is make it more Dynamic
and I think it's very natural to
incorporate you know the rapid and Blitz
into the system so that's again that's
what capable to see that's why we have
millions and millions of new followers
they just they
like it or not nobody wants to
wait eight hours for the result of the
game yeah now maybe you can play some of
them but you also need it like you know
you have opera music but you also have
other forms of music so you cannot have
just just you know long Wagner
operations that's the only dish in the
menu
final question ding the red play against
Johnny palmyachi do you think that the
winner of this match a match if it runs
the risk of being placed the same as
halifman or kasimjanova's a world
champion with the big asterisk look is
the
it's more likely you know uh yeah you
can go back to karp of demon match
because yeah California they were not
even top 10 when they won the title they
had to feed the titles uh here we're
talking about
okay you may start arguing three four
but two top five players so as they yeah
and that's that's the difference but um
I don't know what kind of title they can
carry so I mean I I definitely will not
will never uh consider the winner of
this match if this match takes place as
a seven-ness world champion so just for
me the only way for the 17th world
champion to to to to appear someone to
be added to the list that started with
steinits it's to beat microscrolls or if
he walks away then it's another story
but as long as Madness is playing is
this is It's you can't you know you
can't consider you know uh any match a
real world championship match by the way
go and go away back so that's what we
know from history though it's still a
little bit of mystery because a long
time ago uh the reason why the official
match first official match was was
declared in 1886 though the shinings
played I understand that was stupid
because nobody was was ready to accept a
title as long as morphy was alive Murphy
died in 1883 and only after morphy's
death they were ready to to play the
match that chess public accepted as as
as a world championship match there you
go the 13th world champion says if
someone doesn't beat Magnus over the
board in a match that's not going to be
the 17th I'm sure everybody's going to
have their own opinions for that Gary
thank you for joining us here in the
show we're minutes away actually I'm one
minute away
absolutely you want to stay with us just
have a look let's see what are the
parents that we have uh here we got MV
114 as well okay
what a nice coincidence
nobody believes us it's a coincidence
yeah we are just about a moment away
from sorry we can just imagine plays
white and Magnus plays white yeah you
want to analyze this one yeah let's have
a look of course that's the it's the
it's uh Emilio Bible had a good chance
against Magnus you know this I was
surprised he didn't push Pawn on H6
right it was it looks scary for the
world champion there yeah but it was it
was see how he was under pressure and
then there was at one point he could
have played H6 check instead in his
interview the check and then take the
Knight you can even look at that yes
this is yeah that's I and it would be
yeah this is the
yeah here is the moment yes no here yet
here here is the moment play H6 right of
course H6 check and then take the Knight
and then take the Knight with all these
dark Square Witnesses yeah it was just
King F6 G5 doesn't work this is that's
the point he says two weeks so you
should go there then you take and you
should play F6 but then you start
pushing pawns here because G5 you always
have this this is this there so there's
a chance it's I'm not saying it's it's
it's it's it's the only winning but but
it's a very very good chance and if you
could have okay and the game is on its
way Magnus using this kind of music is
his favorite line his Queen takes D4
Maxima actually had a great prep against
him in the rapid I don't know yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but but it's um
well we'll see so just re this is the
famous little Bishop h65 this is some
sort of a very interesting wine yeah and
five F5 computer chess
pass move
seriously okay
F5 yes
seriously seriously
seriously this is why the 10 year olds
are good at just not computers have
changed the game so much that five is
currently considered to be the best move
fan but it's getting worse and worse for
black yeah I think after Bishop B2 in
this position the move is Bishop H6
exactly that's that's what I said no no
no F6 and this dynamism yes yeah the
dynamic you go but in this position with
Bishop G7 I I thought this was actually
considered to be bad for black of course
it's blood
it looks bad five
world champion now in this belief that
this is even playable for the black side
so this looks horrible for black
so explain it already said a little bit
what is it that
you think is was going to be causing
black trouble here
yeah I don't like this
I can't even explain though so it's
maybe it's not that bad but I just I
don't like uh this is they come somehow
it's a combination rooms at five Queen
F5 Bishops there's no plans F5 visual
six Knight F6 I understand because this
is you try to be dynamic so just it's
the you you you create Wiggles in your
position but you you know you try to
compensate it by the activities right as
of now I could see yeah weaknesses but
yeah but a knight D5 killing that
activity trying to get some uh just
taking away the pieces from the board
leaving those weaknesses behind yeah
well that's just this end game take take
will be eight now
the rugby doesn't ugly move to make
F7
okay you have seven on the board
it just feels terrible right Knight F3
coming Knight G5 on top
Bishop C4 baby
Bishop c495 maybe yeah
it doesn't bother
he just wants to create you know
weaknesses Bishop of five he may
probably Place F4 and then there's
another three so Magnus it's just a
typical you just you know have some
slight Advantage so this is the in black
black position in the center slightly
compromised okay okay not compromised
but this is yeah it's it's maybe not
much but it's just it Magnus I think
we'll enjoy it no it's two point idols
and against three I mean everything that
black has done not compensated
now a fortnite free
let's find out the world champion in
thought so far A little bit of a slogan
for a blitz Bishop C4 he wants to force
95
and then go back this bit back back and
then F4
and that's what's going on 906 on the
board
yeah no he should probably not take him
then then therefore
yes ten minutes maybe it's not that you
know clear this F4 baby G4 than anyone
now G4 yeah
maybe it's not
D5 maybe was not the greatest idea
Knight D5 still returns that Advantage
nice F6 played and well the computer's
loving your idea Knight takes F6 King
takes F6 follow it up with F4 but that's
that's the that's the most natural and
then Bishop maybe go on a three and then
he has G4 and then Knight D2 so it's the
end again this is this pawn star it's
the squeeze right it's a yeah that's the
the the the I mean if you have you know
uh queens and somebody's attacks is fun
but this it's the aesthetic static
problems the static problems yeah so
Knight C6
I think bishoper Freeman also play the
bishop 97 yes I love that little Bishop
F3 it's so natural to play Knight F3 but
not as accurate I'm not sure maybe now
maybe now
so uh
wants to put I don't know it's the
Bishop of three years exactly 92. left
well we're all Champions right
still yeah Bishop Bishop before Rook F1
this looks really bad actually it's not
bad but it's just you know it's the
black has no no come to play and for
Magnus is just you know it's uh it's a
favorite type of it's absolutely so
that's like
and yeah time wise so this is time was
about even 244 for magnets and three
minutes
there was the they must have the world
championship match and this is I mean
playing f500 Bishop G7 what's the point
although when Napo came in he said he
was in no mood to repeat the lines from
the world championship and he was
preparing the patch off there
yeah I know but it's just still well
Magnus to find a better move Knight C5
and that's history oh
this King I'll have to say the activity
difference of the pieces yeah
you can almost make the moves
automatically right rookie one coming
well yes maggots don't have to think yep
and 95
. see it doesn't feel like black is
creating a thread but holding on for now
how do you break through in this
position
and I think we should play C4 now
I would say because e6d5 I just want to
avoid this play probably probably
e95 as well E5
and perhaps that's why Magnus is
considering his move here I've got C4
player
exactly like each other no because he
sees E6 you don't want e65 so that's
that's the you want to yeah
and Knight is
um
yeah
rookie three is immediately targeting
that movement exactly
I would have Friday maybe I would have
tried if I was still bad still pretty
nasty because it's just the black has no
come to play and you can see with the
last one was h6a6 not really creating
very much yet
B5 does seem like an idea back to life
before 97.
497 yes still yeah it's still still
surviving still surviving yes maybe G4
G4 G4 G4 F5 G4
I love you for just making that King
weak or Rook H3 played immediately it
wasn't immediately
I would start with G4 I mean why not G4
getting some time maybe rookie three
pack
and I love the move G4
start attack you know the case plays B5
you can take on B5 and then F5 not
worried about the counter play there
right yeah but people are also weak so
yeah with code contact the A7 is there
and then you see if he takes them this
is the
[Laughter]
yeah it's so complicated to create
anything Knight D7 97 voluntarily yeah
that's this he's trying to oh that's
five anyway so it's there it doesn't go
that a knight comes to E5
but it's the
95 was the the only move is now because
taking
them to expose the king 95 played and
without the five I would have probably
wait and probably yes you do
all right because the move 97 was geared
against that yeah exactly yeah so this
is Maybe
it's the I would have
not rush you know with with the five A4
A4 takes takes
feels like with the Knight on E5 but
it's the it's five was was definitely
premature H4 just move you know continue
this Advance there or maybe A4 if you
want to play A4 and A5 so but why why
don't D7 I don't know what's what was
Black's next move right now what would
these machines best suggestion here
uh that says 97 it likes to move Knight
C3 is the best move or H3 just keeping
the position yeah so this is this f55
was Improvement still you know it's
interesting so because it's an attack
but but here's some come to play well
players are down to about just over a
minute each
remember they do have those two seconds
still unpleasant
yeah
it's Modern Age six is just about to
drop yeah because this is the second
Rook also will come yes yeah so Rook G2
check this is H3 is all right
I think that's my nap was taking so long
in this move he doesn't see a good way
to defend the pawn
where's the counter play
B5 there we go
all right what is the point of this if I
take this is the only chance of this he
wants to he wants to die you know
but if I simply take two times what's
happening
I think the king is safe on B4 right
okay absence for before absolute seven
before
see no yeah there you go a takes B5 as
well I see no oh Rook C5 hitting the
Knight and the pawn
Knight C3 on Rook cheek so I guess you
have roquito
so just this is his nose I could see I
could see a passport yeah what I see it
I see his passport okay it's winning
it's winning now after V5 was winning
yes it's Woody now yeah not this winning
yeah but the B5 I'm sure what was what
was the best move instead of B5 here
rookie yeah but that's the yeah that's
the and then tries to hold the ending
yes exactly yes but that's very true you
know ideas a59 very interesting idea
actually this is a59 C6 basically
they're keeping you know King on A3 okay
but now it's yes that's it works here
and that's gonna be a second point
yeah but that's the
Rook takes H6 on the board now go down
to 20 seconds as well not a lot of time
for him but it's not about 20 seconds
it's about it's about that position
that's also true check blocks of the
Knight
that's it that's it right that's it
magnificent that's it that's it
through G4 Rook takes A4 last last
three just solid move there you go world
champion I know
B6 on the board Rook B5
is the matter of technique at this point
F6
Rook C7
group before okay last chance
nope
six Works C3
and
meanwhile Wesley is so I'm being told
has won his game against Stephen
Dominguez we'll take a look at those
games after this one
and well it's becoming a little
complicated
not a lot of progress so far for Magnus
yeah seems a bit F6 at one point he
could have played I guess I suggested
we'll go back to the position Rook on F1
is it getting dicey
no that's three
Knight C3 was great
it's Fork on D5 this King on F6 you're
so such in a bad position
oh it's a queen
that is a queen
is coming or C6 played with one second
on the clock
and he's resigned yeah well this is the
earthquake king of seven move like King
F7 here so this is interesting he always
you know stole you know Magnus
Unstoppable this was a big chance for
Netflix with the black pieces but uh
there was no chance there was no chance
the moment they reach this end game so I
think I'm very clear that's this so
what's happened today in the realm so
it's the who is who's behind Magnus now
nobody is uh there's nobody that's
basically yeah that's basically the
answer Magnus is in first place and
there's a bunch of people somewhere
somewhere else I think we have dinner on
time
uh we're gonna go to studio in St Louis
to call the last games remaining and uh
well the start of it is all about over
guys okay thank you uh Gary Gary proving
that he still knows how to move the
pieces Miro as he was pretty